y
[Música]
i
argentina atraviesa el momento más
difícil de la pandemia de kobe 19 mucho
más duro que los momentos más
complicados del año 2020 con días con
más de 35 mil casos reportados con más
de 500 muertes incluso con días de más
de 700 muertes informadas y sobre todo
con mucha presión en el servicio del
sistema de salud sobre todo en las
terapias intensivas se llevó a esta
situación según algunos por un
relajamiento de las medidas restrictivas
también por un cansancio general en la
población después de un confinamiento
muy largo y muy duro en 2020 y también
por un retraso en la llegada de dosis de
vacunas en este contexto el gobierno
dispuso un cierre muchísimo más estricto
del 22 al 30 de mayo y también durante
el primer fin de semana de junio con la
expectativa de controlar entonces si
esta segunda ola de kobe 19 en argentina
[Música]
en méxico a diferencia de otros países
de américa latina de acuerdo con las
autoridades se registra un descenso
persistente de la pandemia en todos los
indicadores tanto en muertes como en
contagios y hospitalizaciones a la fecha
el país lleva acumuladas 221 mil muertes
por ccoo mil 19 un promedio actual
diario de 156 muy lejos de los 1000
fallecimientos diarios en promedio
registrados en enero pasado en cuanto a
contagio se tiene un promedio diario de
2100 esto es 12% del pico alcanzado en
enero de este año la ciudad de mexico
que fuera el epicentro de la epidemia en
el país se encuentra en semáforo
amarillo y se alista para volver a
clases presenciales el próximo 7 de
junio cuando ya todos los maestros estén
vacunados el presidente lópez obrador ha
estimado que para octubre todos los
mexicanos estarán ya vacunados al menos
con una primera dosis en el país se han
aplicado 26 millones de dosis a cerca de
18 millones de personas
[Música]
d
debido a que más de 450 casos
registrados
la semana de mayo según las autoridades
sanitarias
del estado de emergencia
d
decirlo ya que aquí la población
[Música]
combate la misión
un mes antes de recibir un primer dosis
de vacunas de un total
a los escépticos de la necesidad de
vacunarse será una campaña muy difícil
para el gobierno que gobiernos ya la vez
victoria
[Música]